everybody for Atlanta hey Reuben boy
dudu BAM looks like it's a little cold
out there right yeah we got some snow
this morning I'm here on the set of our
film this is our San Francisco set which
as you know is also where Eddie Brock is
from up until this point we've had a
completely closed set no visitors no
press nobody's been here so you guys are
the first people in the entire world to
visit our stages we have a couple of
questions for you
kenna tell us a little about the movie
cuz anyone who's read the comics has
seen a lot of different vanos throughout
the years and which iteration of the
character will be in this movie
well we want to be as true as possible
to the comics with our film but our
story is primarily based on the lethal
protector and the planet of the
symbiotes books and can you give us a
little hint of what fans can expect to
see in venom sure I can promise you
badass action Venom's dark humor and I
can also promise you and absolutely
stunning performance by Tom Hardy
this is Venom's movie so we never know
where he's going to show up we're
creating the next link in the chain
yeah I thought I'd introduce it to my
good friend Tom Hardy here my partner in
crime
aka Eddie Brock
many people Wow hey hey I'm so sorry
that I can't be with you we were going
to actually surprise you but flying in
we're gonna take the flight it's like
nine and a half hours overnight and then
we're gonna jump back and go back to set
but the snow kept us on the ground so
I'm really sorry that we can't be there
with you now
Wow we wanted to come to South Powell
and we wanted to come to Brazil I've
never been I'm a huge fan so anyway I
just wanted to say that I give you my
word of honor that I'm going to do
everything I can to deliver the best
venom that I possibly can muster because
I know how important he is to you and I
know how important he is to the Marvel
Universe I don't know how important this
is for all of us here so that's what
we're doing and anyway since I can't be
there I've got one of these really cool
t-shirts right which is the only bit of
official memorabilia there anybody I've
modified mine so you're gonna have to
modify your own but we left you one each
and other guys will be giving you one
and it's got the Brazilian flag on
I hope you can see that but that's for
you thank you so much Sao Paulo I'm
sorry that we can't be with you and I
well maybe next time
[Applause]
GameStop so now
we
who
hey everybody so we finally got our
first look at the venom movie and they
confirmed that it's going to be a
version of Planet of the symbiotes cross
with lethal protector I've already done
a couple videos about the stories for
those but that might have something to
do with the origin of the Venom symbiote
or they could set it in the future the
way that the Logan movie was set in the
future so that it is part of the
spider-man mythos because they're
building themselves a spider verse and
you can't do that without spider-man if
you're just finding me for the first
time there's all kinds of spider-man
dropping this year so be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos so of
course there's still a billion questions
about how Tom Hollands version of
spider-man is going to figure into all
these other movies but I think they're
still figuring that out from behind the
scenes like they just want to make a
really awesome venom movie over the next
year so before it goes into
post-production and then they'll figure
out the spider-man of it all like they
can develop a spider-man stinger
separately from all this Tom Hardy stuff
you don't actually need to have
spider-man in the bulk of the movie
because lethal protector was basically
spider-man telling Eddie Brock that I
will let you go free as long as you get
the hell out of New York City that's why
the director was saying that their film
set is of San Francisco like he said
that it's been a closed set so no one
has seen what they've been doing
although there been some spy shots like
you see Tom Hardy just like
gesticulating around because it seems
like they're gonna do the venom soup
motion capture which is probably the
smart way to go because if you watch
Robert Downey jr. walking around the
Avengers sets he's like the gold
standard now for actors they can just
walk around with dots on them do their
performance and then they'll add the
suit in post-production later so with a
few exceptions like you actually see him
running when they're getting ready for
that big Airport battle there are some
reference shots that they need so
they're probably a couple of times when
Tom Hardy's walking around on set with a
version of the venom costume on but
that's probably been behind doors so
that nobody with a spy camera or a drone
could spot him yet the biggest thing
about this is that they haven't shown us
what the costume looks like this is
basically their Brazil Comic Con panel
remember Ryan Reynolds did that funny
teaser for Comic Con I'll post a link to
that at the end of this but Brazil Comic
Con has become a pretty big place for
studios to drop footage for the
International territories so if you live
outside the United
States and you don't go to San Diego
comic-con this is actually one of the
best conventions to go to see footage
most of the big studios will go down
there taking stuff I know there still a
billion questions about how carnage is
supposed to figure into this he's still
a rumor at this point we don't know for
sure that he's gonna do him but
everybody is pretty sure he's gonna be
in there
the thing about Planet of the symbiotes
is that it's really just like this outer
space invasion of symbiotes spider-man
has to team up with venom and Scarlet
Spider to fight them off and it also
involves the symbiotes left over from
lethal protector select the five
different versions of Venom's costume
that become their own symbiotes are
still around it also serves as a
continuation of the carnage origin story
because he's only recently been bonded
to the carnage symbiote there's a number
of different ways that they could mix
and match those two stories to tell the
origin of the carnage symbiote if it's
not going to be exactly like it was in
the comics because the carnage symbiote
is really just the offspring of the
Venom symbiote so there's still a lot of
questions about that they cast Riz Ahmed
but he's basically in charge of the lab
that's responsible for trying to clone
the Venom symbiote so but what they
might do because Riz Ahmed is a
relatively big actor is they could end
up giving him the carnage symbiote at
the end of the movie even though that's
not the way that it goes down in the
comics but he's a pretty evil character
it would make venom seem like more of an
antihero and it's kind of the direction
they're going with lethal protector but
they did say it's gonna be a little bit
more agent venom origin story for the
Venom symbiote but there is a new round
of that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on the video
announce a winner when I post my
Avengers video in a couple hours we have
to talk all about Avengers 4 there's
that black widow movie talk there's all
kinds of crazy Marvel stuff happening
click here for that funny Deadpool Comic
Con video and click here for all my
other venom videos thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
you